yeah and then the final reveal new IP
SSX tricky meets the wingsuit challenge
from Just Cause meets the wingsuit from
bar cry it's steep hmm I'm kind of a
little confused about this game like
yeah you said during the the trailer who
is this for yeah my dream sports fan but
I saw the trailer I was just thinking
man wouldn't a new SSX game yeah good
yes instead with bit stuck the game that
doesn't it doesn't seem like it knows
what it wants to be like there are
moments was like yay extreme sports and
then there were people laughing at the
characters gang her and then it was like
an almost environmental message of like
love the mountains and sites it was a
little confused yeah yeah although I
mean oh sorry Lucy oh no I was gonna say
it kind of felt like it was trying to
put the tricky stuff in but the dip but
it was doing very seriously it tried to
do you know when you you bail in trials
and you do the quick restart it tried to
look like it was doing that it's put a
photo mode in it's got what looks like
kind of the crew you know like people
seamlessly joining you and beating and
challenges and stuff so overall it just
looks like a very ubisoft game in a
completely different I'd never would
have expected this to be honest in the
game's defense I do like the idea of a
game that is almost more exploration
driven than maybe we're giving it credit
for it yes like it is sort of just about
hey you're on a mountain you have the
freedom to kind of go and do what you
want and just sort of feel immersed in
this environment I think for certain
people that's going to be very appealing
and the idea that you have multiple
activities to engage in while you're in
that environment yeah hopefully it'll be
enough to keep you busy and and have
some fun with the game I mean I think
I'm itching to actually play it and
figure out what it's really trying to do
but you know I'm intrigued I don't want
to completely write it off just yet I
really do wonder how much of an audience
there is for a very simp kind of very
bland looking you know skiing or you
know extreme sports type game like the
ones that are memorable and the ones
that have the best chance of succeeding
are the ones that are like a little over
two over the top in a way like yeah I
hate to bring up SSX tricky again but
it's never like the kind of simple this
is how exactly how it would feel to be
skiing that really clack captured
everyone's imagination
always a spin on it in the same way that
for example a simulation racing game is
90 Forza is good but like Forza horizon
is where it's fun and is well really
people love and talk about it in the
same way that you know SSX with 3 or vs
SSX tricky which one do they talk about
its everyone loves tricky like middle of
the you know the very bland simulation
style games but I'm sure there will be
an audience but I don't know I feel like
they're kind of limiting themselves by
trying to be like very you know serious
tone we're going to explore the
mountains and you're going to be one
with nature no we need to do like
backflips and putting off against nature
tomorrow come on down with nature is
what I say I find it quite a surprising
given that this is the you know you be
30 I I imagine more of a big blockbuster
at the end I guess I mean steep will
find its audience but I don't know if
it's as mass market as some of the other
titles only the audience is not the
people in this couch to be honest we
don't really go outside yeah that's
wrong all the reason to play this game
instead that's true also there was a
game I think it came out um it was
definitely being in development fierce
forward snow I think it was called yes
yeah first person i played in the oculus
once and that was when I saw steep i
mentioned playing that in VR yeah would
be more interesting than playing it
normally yeah until you do a flip tell
you like then throwing on having fun I'm
gonna do it
you